were you in the wrestle I mean
everybody's been asking you're going to
do a new out like you're going to do an
album with them yeah we're talking about
it
it's timing it's just trying to figure
it out like he got a lot going on I got
a lot going on we've definitely been
like talking a lot more
um anytime I'm in the bay I always go
over to his spot we always link up but
it's like every time we link up
it's more of like a
it's more of like a conversation than it
is about music because we so inspired
about being Innovative that we always
trying to think of like what's the next
move for the future more so than making
a song right so it's it's definitely
gonna come it's just timing it's a
matter of time yeah who else from the
bay are you [ __ ] with J.R stoked yeah
that's my boy right there I just brought
him out in Vegas young J.R he's dope I
like little Kayla uh Rex life Raj
um who else I've been listening to
I also like that kid I think his name is
DB by the bag but I think these are like
Stockton or something like this
Stockton's going up right now yeah he's
dope
um it's a few people that's dope blaster
there's a few people I rock with us got
some great [ __ ] going on